hello everyone welcome to rational
science
and this site deals with physics so if
you're not interested in physics you are
in the wrong site
today we are going to be dealing with
this issue okay let's get right to it
if i get it up here why is there
something rather than nothing
have you ever asked yourself that
question well some people say
everybody should ask themselves that
question and the question is
whether everyone has not everybody seems
to be asking that question
anyways um i looked up on the internet
several people who attempted to answer
that question
and today we're going to listen to their
voices okay here's one fella
um his name is leo gura
and uh he's got a million followers and
typically when there's
a million followers you know something
is wrong
wrong because the majority of people are
religious people
and uh they don't understand anything
about anything and they just follow
gurus like this gentleman here okay what
does he say about
this question he says this is what
nothing looks like
right first he's gonna they find nothing
for us or give us a notion of what
nothing is
in his mind right not some imaginary
nothing but actual nothing i like that
because actual is a synonym of real
of exist and he's going to talk about
nothing that exists
okay and that's what happens as you can
see you're gonna see that the problem
here is that he doesn't define his terms
that's that's
gonna be the problem he says but actual
nothing actual nothing has colors
uh actual nothing talks
actual nothing here is an actual nothing
is a bird flying through the air
actual nothing is indistinguishable from
something
everything is nothing
that's like when people say god is
everything
and that means god is really nothing
there because they haven't understood
squad
you know if god is everything what is
god in fact uh
god is also nothing that means god is
becomes a meaningless word
that's what's going to happen with jeff
but this follow um
he says you have to visualize or you
have to imagine
okay nothing has a black hole as a black
void
but he says or he adds that he says but
even a black void
is something okay
so he continues says what reality is
is purely unbiased unrestricted
unlimited
consciousness and every time i hear the
word consciousness i know i'm dealing
with a religious
individual a spiritualist okay uh
in other words a person who has no clue
about anything uh you're conscious
you you oh i said you are conscious now
that's uh what reality is made of
so he thinks that reality existence has
to do
with what you personally perceive
in other words we always have that issue
in ordinary speech
when we say that um whatever you think
is real
that's what's real to you and so that's
the notion of ordinary speech
of the people out there on the streets
it's not a scientific notion
of what reality or what exists means and
that's where the problem is uh not
defining what exists is what
reality is and just using the word from
ordinary speech and says hey
whatever's real to you is is real
and no that's that can't be true because
that's first of all it's subjective
then if you're high on drugs or whatever
you know whatever hallucinations you
have
you know that's not real out here that's
not real to all of us what's real is
what's objective what's
what everybody sees not when one guy
sees that's not real okay if you see
ghosts
you know you might say well that's my
reality well no then you can't use the
word reality
in science like that in ordinary speech
you can say whatever you want you can
say that
love exists in science you can't do that
okay it says you're conscious now
that's what reality is made up the
substance of the of reality is
consciousness consciousness
is what nothing we learned a lot oh man
uh see all these guys talk about poetry
essentially
and uh and that's let's see if i get
this thing here
uh give me a second here
get myself organized
um so so what's real the one person is
not
objective it's subjective and the big
problem here is that he's not defining
his terms
okay so keep keep those things in mind
we're going to go forward
and this is what this file says
continues
or tries to say here this this is his
vision of reality of how he sees the
universe or
nothing and something in fact the
present moment and the
entire universe and all of reality is
nothing
what sense does that statement make i
mean you know obviously
he's reciting poetry here he's uh he's
playing with words
mumble jumble that's how it is uh no
wind nowhere and no how
uh he says it's an illusion all that
okay and this is why
science and the human mind and the human
intellect and rationality
and logic struggle so much to answer
metaphysical questions such as why there
is something
rather than nothing yeah they struggle
because like this fall he doesn't define
his terms that's why they struggle
because they have no clue
whenever they don't define their terms
okay and
um then he says because the analytical
mind
i guess he's got a problem with the
analytical mind with a rational mind
uh he'd rather be irrational okay that's
fine that's his choice
uh the analytical mind only works based
upon certain uh premises
and certain assumptions and certain
fundamental distinctions like the
distinction between something and
nothing
well yeah you have to define these
things in order to be able to talk
sensibly otherwise
you talk irrationally okay and it means
that you have a subjective religion
and yeah you can believe in anything you
want but it doesn't mean that
you've made your case not in the realm
of science between something existing
and non-existing between something being
logical and illogical yeah when you
don't define these terms you can talk
about this all day long and chase your
tail around like this file does
and that explains why he's got a million
followers in great measure
but all of these are biases within
consciousness reality can only exist
reality exists existence exists uh i
heard that before a rand
precisely because it is perfectly
symmetrical whatever that means okay
such that it cancels itself out and
infinite singularity of
everything superimposed on top of itself
into a perfect unity a perfect symmetry
such that we could say that none of it
even exists
well i hope you learned something from
this fellow he chased his tail around he
says everything exists nothing exists
uh consciousness is nothing nothing
exists and
he said nothing but these are the
fellows that you know have uh
lots of followers because they are
religious fanatics uh whether they
believe in god or not is irrelevant but
they're religious because first they
don't define their terms second
they uh harp on belief that's why an
opinion
on subjectivity that's why they're
religious individuals
okay let's see what the fatal problems
are here uh here's uh
first set this is uh uh the first
couple of problems with the with leo's
reasoning okay
subjectivity introducing an observer
okay
science we don't use observers it's in
the religion of mathematical physics
where they introduce observers and
obviously is a follower of mathematical
physics he
takes everything through authority what
uh the mathematical establishment has
proven and this is what he regurgitates
to his followers
leo talks about what you visualize when
someone says nothing
okay he suggests black hole black void
etc he unjustifiably introduces
consciousness
in other words he says well what is
reality to you what is real to you
no no we don't care what's real to you
it's got to be real to the whole
universe to the whole planet
okay so if there's a wall there or uh or
i always say you know you have you throw
a rock through a window
and you show that to everybody say how
did the window break everybody says the
same thing well a rock went through the
window
now that's known as objectivity and
physics everybody
saw an experience etc the same thing
okay
and but he's saying no what did you
experience what did you see when you
were on drugs or whatever
you know that's subjective so this is
not an issue of using senses
or the mind this is an issue of
definitions
okay that's how we determine these
things objectively we define
and just follow through with the
definition that's what it is
and so we go with the definitions
important in this case what is something
what is nothing this one i'll never
define him i mean he goes says
consciousness is nothing nothing is
nothing that's exists and also doesn't
exist
whatever all that meant okay and so uh
yeah until he defines
nothing rigorously okay uh we have no
idea what he's talking about so we
define it for them something that we
just shape
okay and those are the synonyms and
nothing that which doesn't have shape
we have these two are words are antonyms
and now we can use these two terms
consistently we know what we're talking
about
if it has shape we're going to call it
something if it doesn't have shape
whatever you're pointing to you're
pointing to nothing okay that's it
uh when you point to the moon uh you
point to something and when you point to
the
black stuff around it can you point to
that well you're not really pointing to
that because
uh you're treating that black stuff as
something okay and for that first we got
to define what that black stuff is we
define it as what
that which doesn't have shape if it
doesn't have shape you're pointing to
nothing whatever that means to you
okay so yeah the moon is something it
was
around it that black stuff that's known
as nothing space space is nothing
okay and here's the second set of uh
problems with uh
leo's reasoning okay uh
he equates nothing with meaningless
okay and he went there let's see if i
can get that back up here
uh he said where was it
uh i think it was this one yeah
he said uh go through all this gibberish
about you know nothing has uh
colors uh nothing talks actual nothing
hears
what does all that mean what is that
nonsense and so
he's just saying that all this is
meaningless like
meaningless words and what that means to
him is nothing so
that's what he's equating it to he's not
saying uh what nothing means for the
purposes of science of physics
in other words space right uh vacuum
uh he's just saying that whatever
nothing means is
just a meaningless it's meaningless so
when you talk about a chair
what meaning does a chair have it has no
meaning so that's nothing you're
pointing to nothing
that that's his reasoning if you could
call it reasoning okay
uh so what is meaningless is ryo's leo's
reasoning
until he defines the strategic terms
that make or break his arguments
game of words that's what it is circular
reasoning because he has not defined the
terms in his dissertation
okay uh then obviously he hasn't defined
a key word exists
real reality okay and he uses the notion
of ordinary speech
and part of that is that uh no one in
the last ten thousand years he find the
word exists
whatever you find in the dictionary i
just synonyms and i've covered that in
the past okay
the definition exists what is it exists
physical presence
it's got to be an object otherwise it
doesn't exist and
of course this destroys a lot of
religions and there's only one solution
for that and that's
you give me a definition you can use
consistently for the word exist
very simple i know we don't use the
senses we don't use the mind
consciousness all that nonsense no
uh we define the term exists and then uh
use it consistently that's the way we do
it in science
in physics so what this guy talks about
is just gibberish
okay okay here's another guy he's got
twice as many followers he's got two
million followers
and again you can see why they follow
them because all they do is just word
wizardry that's all they do
and here this fellow's name is alex
mccachney
okay and uh something caught my eye says
we're the last humans left and i said oh
another guy who
discovered that we're the last humans no
not not even by a mile
and this is what he rises the main point
is that we hope to enjoy the privilege
of being a semicolon
in history rather than a full stop okay
so on behalf of the 150 billion who came
before us and our human cousins who
didn't make it
we just hope this message finds you well
and we hope when you find us thousands
of years from now
okay so he's not saying we have we're we
have um
that extinction is imminent okay uh
thousands of years uh
from now that we are well too no we
won't in fact we don't have to wait a
thousand years from now because
extinction of our species is imminent
it's about to happen any moment now okay
uh in any case please just write back
it's dark over here and we're the last
humans left
now we're not uh what he was referring
to was he went through the different
hominids
and he says look we're the last hominids
left
okay there's no more yeah we're the last
dynasty and that gives you an idea that
we can't go very far
partly because we've been around for 200
000 years we've been inbreeding
on the one hand but more important than
that our economy is going to
go goes out the global economy will
collapse and that's going to be the end
of all of us no one will produce
or distribute food to the cities okay
and that's when
billions will die uh and that's coming
up
i think uh might happen this year for
all we know i mean you know it's
right around the corner we're not too
far away from that whether months or
years we're not too far away from that
okay um i like how he starts uh
this fellow alex uh why is there
something rather nothing he says these
are unacceptable answers okay
god did it yeah well then what did uh
god
he says and i think that's that's a
typical
issue you know who created god uh second
if you say i don't care
well he says yes you do the stuff you're
made of is 13 billion years old
where did he get that big bang okay
that's what these people have been
brainwashed into mathematical physics
and just take all the all that
mathematics feeds to them as real as
as a done deal they never even question
it okay even though
13 billion years ago what is a big bang
is creationism and a lot of these guys
on the one hand claim to be atheist but
then they talk about belief and
subjectivity meaning that they are
religious individuals
they don't really even realize that okay
and she said you should give a damn the
reality is
maybe more than 80 i'd say 85 percent of
humanity doesn't give a damn about that
issue so i think 85 would answer i don't
care people have bigger problems
uh underhand you know where they're
going to live uh how they're going to
make their next buck
some people in some parts of the world
they don't even have a house or
or uh even running water you know there
are all kinds of people out there
and they don't enjoy all these luxuries
of thinking about the universe they've
got bigger things on their mind so
if i were to run a poll eight billion
people on the planet i would say maybe
85 percent of them
don't care about this issue so he's
wrong he says you should care yeah but
that's only when you've got your
tummy filled okay maybe we're just too
stupid to work it out
uh yeah as far as the mathematicians i
would say yeah
mathematical physics has never been able
to work out this issue
and he says which is what everyone says
shortly before someone works something
out
and he's right there so he's getting 10
points for that one
okay he continues he says there are two
possibilities
okay when you analyze this question you
know why is there something rather than
nothing he says
there's two answers here everything uh
either came out of nothing for no
reason at all okay everything has always
been around forever
okay i think it's a pretty good start i
mean at least he's
uh he's in the ballpark okay and
and so this is this is what he proposes
okay he proposes
uh something like the uh oscillating
universe okay
he invokes time he said what if the
universe was caused from its own future
so we have an ending to the universe
right and then it starts all over again
like a uh again the oscillating universe
theory where you know
the end uh is the beginning of the next
universe the end of our universe at the
beginning of the next one
modern physics might allow for it oh it
doesn't you mean mathematical physics
not
not physics but it wonderful property of
nothing is that it makes
some things okay i'll talk about that in
a few seconds
how can something not have a beginning
uh yeah that's the universe we propose
we say that
uh matter cannot come from absolutely
empty space
and so yes something can come from with
a does not have a beginning or can come
from uh
can't come from nothing okay and right
now we don't have a clue
not scientists not philosophers not
theologians we don't even know where to
start
so here uh this guy uh uh
intends to talk about a subject which he
knows nothing about
absolutely love it and maybe that
explains why he's got two million
followers
okay yeah because he's going to talk
about something he knows nothing about i
guess
people like to listen to a fellow like
him and say yeah
we're also you know we don't know
anything they like to hear that and they
probably give them a like
right is that why they watch this guy
for the for him to tell him
i don't know i mean i don't i really
don't understand humanity in that sense
okay here's another little more well
known his name is jim holt he's a writer
he
wrote i think for the new york times
philosopher newsmen
okay and he wrote a book because he
dedicated some time researching this
subject
why does the world exist and he tried to
answer this question why is there
something
rather than nothing okay and he says
this is the super
ultimate why question you know why does
a universe exist
well right there and then we already
have a problem universe is a concept
concepts don't exist
and uh then you know he says exist
like he knows what he's talking about
and again i'm sure you look through his
whole book
you won't find it the definition for the
word exist
okay he says uh this is from a video he
he had i think uh ted talked i'm going
to talk about the mystery the puzzle of
existence oh man i love it finally
someone who can answer the question
great let's listen
he starts out right he says uh it's
physics that deals with existence
he hit that one on the nose yeah physics
belongs exclusively to physics
it does not belong to religion so when
theologians say oh the existence of god
or atheists talk
no god doesn't exist no no no they've
all crossed the line into physics
whenever you use the word exist in any
formal way you've crossed the line into
physics whether you know it or not
physics
has exclusive control property ownership
of the word exist or anything related to
existence he starts out by mentioning uh
larry krauss
who wrote i talked about him in the past
uh he wrote a book universe from nothing
okay and he doesn't quote him but he
essentially um
summarizes what larry thinks or says
okay and he says the state-of-the-art
physics can show how
out of sheer nothingness whatever
nothingness is because
there he also had a problem there okay
uh no space no time
no matter nothing okay a little nugget
of false vacuum can fluctuate into
existence
okay tell me how what's the mechanism
right and then by the miracle of
inflation
this is the uh alan guth's some i don't
know why they call him guth
i think it should be pronounced guth but
well okay whatever uh the miracle
created this inflation's theory that
shortly after the big bang there was
this
exponential uh increase in whatever
in whatever substance was there at the
time okay whatever
god had created by that time i guess i
don't know uh but it comes from this
um you can call it quantum foam which is
what one of the things being kicked
around okay
but he says this false vacuum quantum
foam whatever they want to call they use
these terms
and so they have this false vacuum and
by the miracle of the inflation this
exponential multiplication of that
false vacuum okay blow up into this huge
variegated uh cosmos we see around us
okay
uh whole he dismisses this as religion
he says well you know that's like ad hoc
like
you put this false vacuum in there by
hand you know i mean where did that come
from
and he says even honking stephen hawking
was puzzled
after giving his explanation how the
universe came to be and
kind of concluded that you know you
can't solve the problem of existence
with equations
okay which is totally true totally true
math has nothing to do at all with this
problem
so anyone who says hey you know i'm
gonna do this equation this calculation
to find out where the universe came from
no
it's got nothing at all to do with
making something out of nothing which is
the issue before us okay so whenever
people say
let me bring the mathematician over here
he'll tell us he's bringing the wrong
person he's
bringing a person who has no clue what
the question is
let alone the answer okay uh so what is
jim's resolution to this problem okay so
this is what he uh resolves
this is his proposal this is what jim
holt proposes he says the resolution to
the mystery
okay hang on here see we have a
resolution finding ten thousand years we
finally have an answer
to the mystery of existence is that
reality and notice how many times he
uses the word really reality and exists
okay
all those underlying there uh and again
he's never gonna define the term so we
don't know what he's talking about
that the reality we exist in is one of
the generic
realities okay and he's kind of
insinuating the multiverse you know
there's all these universes out there
and there are all kinds of universes
he's going to say that we're kind of
like in the middle of the road and not
at the extremes that's that's
going to be his argument here he says
reality has to turn out some way
it can either turn out to be nothing
which is one extreme you know a universe
where there's nothing in it okay
or everything in other words uh
completely full okay
or something in between where you have
half full like you know maybe
our universe we have some amount of
matter i can't even say half
a lot less than half they say what four
percent of the universe is matter and uh
the rest is
dark matter and dark energy okay so we
have 96 percent of
unknown stuff out there black stuff that
we don't know that they're looking for
and only about four
three four percent is matter okay that's
their notion
and that's what he's talking about and
he says something in between we're in
that in between
so it has some special features okay
listen to this
like being really elegant or really full
or really simple like nothingness that
would require an explanation
you know how can you have a universe
there's nothing in it now that would
he says that requires an explanation but
if it's just one of these
random generic realities you know the
ones in between that have a little bit
of matter
and a bunch of nothing then there's no
further explanation for it
i love how he solved it he says i'm not
gonna answer the question because we
live in a universe where that's in
between we're not in the extreme where
it's all completely full i guess
a single block of matter and the other
one which is just empty space now we
live in between
in these in this universe that has a
little bit of matter and a lot of empty
space and so we don't have to answer the
question
that's his resolution okay and indeed i
would say that that's the reality we
live in that's what science is telling
us
this has been confirmed through
gravitational waves where did he get
that
certainly not out of a kindergarten book
no he got that from all these uh
relativists
the mathematicians people who uh claim
that there's been a big bang
okay and that now we're seeing or
feeling or
or hearing i guess the gravitational
waves come from the big bang and i don't
know how they can distinguish
the gravitational waves coming from a
big bang you know the background
radiation
uh and the ray and the gravitational
waves coming from what two black holes
colliding
i mean how do you distinguish those you
know maybe maybe they're confusing one
with the other you know
the other day they they got a noble for
that right for saying they got
gravitation away from two black holes
colliding didn't see the black holes
colliding they just
said it must have been a big kaboom and
what else could cause it except two
black holes
that's that's the reasoning that's how
they come up with all this stuff they
never saw black on their lives
hopefully not because you know
supposedly when they put their telescope
there and they
peer through there what are they staring
at some light coming from the black hole
black hole that doesn't even allow light
to come out of it unless you have
talking radiation in which case it's
tolerable okay
in other words we have no idea they they
invent loopholes every theory
and they just keep going so there's some
evidence that this is
uh that this really is the reality that
we're stuck in in other words he never
answers the question he says because we
don't have to
that's that's his answer love it and
he's an expert he studied this
subject he wrote a book on a bestseller
just to tell you we don't know
or no no not we don't know uh we don't
have to answer the question
so we have this other vowel who says we
don't know and this guy says
we don't have to answer the question
love love those answers you know
great here's another fella a little more
well known in all of these his name is
sean carroll he's
a mathematical physicist a math magician
he does everything with magic
just like all mathematicians and he says
you have to have
the quantum mechanical laws to begin
with
okay so that's the starting point the
starting point is not zip
the starting point is quantum mechanical
laws so we have these laws written out
there you know someone
legislated and i don't know god maybe
legislated these laws and
he says we have these laws we can't
break the universe can't break matter
can't break these laws okay
fine uh how could you start an empty
space or a quantum vacuum
and then evolve according to the laws of
physics into a universe like we see
we have plausible answers to that
question
so yeah once you start with something he
says the laws
whatever those i mean what are we
talking about concepts here
we started the matter starting from
concepts but he says from those concepts
we have plausibles answers to how matter
came into being from those laws
what the hell is he talking about well
he's talking about what you see there
quantum foam again
you know it's these uh laws of quantum
mechanics he says those are unbreakable
and what is he talking about he's
talking about the uncertainty principle
maybe complementary maybe uh the um
what is it the uh the
exclusion principle maybe maybe he's
talking about those laws
okay and it's like you know those are
unbreakable laws
according to him and that's his starting
point so we have laws
but we have no matter we have only laws
or like um
uh holt is gonna say jim holtz is gonna
say in another context he's gonna say
you know you have it's like you have the
uh nothing space whatever
and you have these laws and when you put
them together that's when the universe
starts
okay that's how quantum enters the
origin of the universe okay
uh so he says uh there are physical
theories that do that
i don't know about physical maybe
mathematical mathematical
theories that say this how matter comes
into being from these laws and nothing
okay and we don't know whether any of
them is right irrelevant that's religion
whether you believe they're right or
wrong that's
got nothing to do with physics uh
subject to against subjective okay
we don't have the final answer to those
questions but it doesn't seem hard
yeah uh and there's no insufferable um
uh obstacle yeah again uh these people
do everything with magic that's why
they're math magicians
they they uh their mechanisms are all
irrational you can't imagine a single
mechanism and the main one is creating
something from nothing which is what
they can't explain
that's the issue but see they all insist
that the universe came into being
one and then it came into being from
nothing
but then they qualify that nothing
because they never defined the word
nothing
and what is nothing well they said these
quantum laws
plus nothing and where did the laws come
from which is what he
he says again you know that this is his
next point he says
where did these laws come from and i
guess
you know i i had to put god in there by
hand because i don't know where the laws
came from who legislated
where was the congress okay and so many
people have in mind the deeper question
of
why is there quantum mechanics in other
words where are these laws of physics
rather than
why are there laws of physics rather
than no laws of physics no thing at all
yeah why are they laws how can you have
absolutely nothing
and laws of physics like these are the
laws
by which the matter which i will create
eventually
will have to abide by i mean
who put these laws into the you know
enforce who who enforces these laws is
that you have no matter but you have the
laws
absolute nonsense but this is what these
people believe that's why they're
religious fanatics
they're not physicists at all okay um
the only plausible answer is why not
now how's that for an answer okay so uh
where do these laws come from how can
they come up from nothing
well why not and again
it's up to you to believe this nonsense
this explanation this this
cop-out i guess that's the best way to
put it why did you ever expect there to
be
nothing rather than something
okay these are the answers they give you
it's not the kind of question in which
we're ever going to get an answer that
says oh it's because of this well yeah
you're never going to answer
the question because you have no answer
how something came from absolute nothing
that's the problem that's the question
we're asking you to answer and you can't
answer and you say well you know we're
never going to be able to answer so what
is this gibberish about the laws of
quantum mechanics underlying
uh or serving as the foundations
for the matter that was created later on
it's like the laws were there nothing
was there and then suddenly
you can put anything in there the laws
will mold it and tell it how to move
and the mathematicians come i guess what
14 billion years later and
describe the motion of particles
and try to figure out what happened on
day one of course they never get there
right okay
uh and what's interesting here look uh
this is like his
corollary and you can see how many times
he used the word exist also here
the brute facts facts that's what
mathematicians talk about
facts proof prediction you know these
these are their words
the brute facts are the laws of physics
not the existence of the universe
okay in the sense of a derivation of the
laws of physics
i think that the laws of physics laws
you know like legislated by god
uh existing existing laws exist how can
laws
what do you mean by exist that's a
different thing than the universe
existing
oh is it okay i can't imagine the laws
of physics existing without a universe
existing
so he's going around in circles chasing
his tail around on the one hand he says
there's these laws and from there
spreading the universe and by universe i
guess he means matter in space because
even space did not exist according to
him and mathematical physics
so we have these laws they're written i
don't know some some kind of laws are
they're floating in
not even in space because space doesn't
exist god doesn't exist yet
but we have the laws and now from those
laws somehow
they move the vacuum the
nothingness which is somethingness and
from there you get the universe whatever
the universe is to him
i guess it's matter and space matter
nothing i mean
these people have to define these terms
in order to talk but they're chasing
their tail around because they don't
define what universe is
what space is what nothing is they don't
define the word exist they don't tell
you what
what a thing is what something is what
an object is we don't have definitions
for any of these
terms in mathematical physics and so
they can talk all day long chasing their
tail around because you have no idea
what they're talking about
they jump from one subject to the other
and you can never stop
and why because these people are not
qualified to do this kind of work what
they are is mathematicians all they do
is mathematics equations all day long
and that's got nothing to do with the
subject
matter at hand the subject matter is how
do you create something from nothing
that's the subject matter can you answer
the question
just say no don't don't give me uh this
run around for half an hour me chasing
your your language around to try to
figure out you know what you're talking
about
because you never define your terms in a
way that an irrational human being can
understand it
okay so he says the universe may have we
have obeys the laws of physics
why so i think they come as a package
you need the universe and you need the
laws because otherwise the laws are
applicable to what to nothing
and what is nothing made out of nothing
is made out of this vacuum foam
okay the laws of physics which are
hidden in there the
false vacuum so we talk about something
or nothing
that's why you have to define these
terms these people say it's nothing but
then they say yeah the nothing is
false vacuum it's this phone quantum
phone that's not nothing
what is this quantum foam is it a
something then don't
tell me it's nothing and again this is
the issue
there is a quantum state that exists a
state what is it next to new york or i
don't know where the state is okay
and it obeys the laws of physics and the
quantum state is the universe
there's a quantum state that evolves
through time according to the laws of
physics
we have an understood squad and you
won't because these people
have no idea what they're talking about
why because they've never defined their
terms
okay final group here fortunately we had
three guys they get together okay and we
have uh neil turek who's a
mathematician also mathematical
physicist uh we have a
fellow who was apparently studied
physics but he went into uh philosophy
of physics
and uh jim hold again he he was in
several of these panels by the way jim
holt yeah i just caught him on one of
them
and this is just a summary of their talk
they had a long talk and so it says alan
guth's uh inflation theory has been
proven
first thing that they concede or or at
least they mentioned that but neil
doesn't believe it because it
assumes that the spring was compressed
he likens the big bang
as a compressed spring okay and so for
whatever reason that spring
popped and you know jack in the box came
out of there okay
and he says uh okay so the spring came
out but he says
who compressed the spring to begin with
that's his issue that's that's where
he's come from
so he he uh says well because uh
uh the whoever was the person who was
handling
questions says well most mathematicians
out there they believe in the multiverse
and he says well he rolled his eyes he
said no no uh not most of in fact uh
most of them have no clue
and he's proposing the oscillating
universe he says like the other fellow
he says there's a start
you know when it ends that's only the
beginning of the next universe so he
likes that theory
and then he says the big bang didn't
start with another our universe did not
start at the big bang
well or maybe it did but the issue is
what preceded that well that another
universe which ended there and then
you know started the new one so the
ending of one universe is the beginning
of another universe or triggers the
beginning of another universe
this is what he he wants to believe in
and he says most
mathematicians out there you know
mathematicians uh they have no clue he
says that's that's his
version okay and he says uh uh we have
today an advantage over people like
saint augustine who also had this notion
remember saint augustine uh let me read
that advantage i was saying augustine is
that today we have observations
saint augustine didn't have that in you
know the uh fourth century
and what are you talking about well you
know in saint augustine he was um
he came up with this notion that god is
outside of time okay so uh
it's really the notion of the block
universe that god is unaffected by
time that uh it's like he's watching all
of creation
simultaneously as for him it's all in
the present mode
so to speak okay and it gives you an
idea of people like uh
who was it peter damien peter damien one
of the doctors of the catholic church
one of the being the brains of the
catholic church and he's a guy who wrote
a book saying that
um god has the power listen to this
god has the power to restore a woman's
virginity
what the god god is all powerful i mean
you can't question that okay god has the
power to restore a woman's virginity and
you say how does he do that i mean
that's kind of odd isn't it and damien
also borrowed on saint augustine the
block universe he says god is really
outside of time and here's this universe
in front of him he sees it all in one
shot
and he doesn't make mistakes the only
mistake he ever made was bill gatey
but he doesn't make mistakes so he makes
the universe in one goal
one shot okay and so what happens um
everything just happens as he planned it
or as he created it
all of time in front of him and he
doesn't make mistakes
so if a woman lost her virginity how
does he
restore it does he take this woman does
he take back in time and he raised that
event
where she lost her virginity and he says
no that's not the way it works see god
makes the universe that's it the
universe is there what's done is done
what what's there is there
and so how does he restore her virginity
well the way he does it he says first
from a point of view
a physical point of view there's no
question there that's where uh
peter damien spent most of his analysis
he said look if god made man
obviously he can do anything physical to
man among them restore
a woman's you know private parts back to
where they were he can do that
in in a future tense after the woman
lost her virginity
so how does he erase the event and it
turns out that
he doesn't erase the event the event is
there but through
um through um
repentance and things of that nature
okay
uh he blesses that person and says okay
your
virginia virginia is restored
so it's uh it's one of those issues that
god kind of pardons you or says okay i'm
gonna restore your virginity
that event it's like never think of it
as it never happened or i'm gonna pardon
you
for whatever you did in the past uh that
that
robbery you made at the bank it happened
but i'm gonna pardon you for it and that
way he restores it morally
and then the physical part well you know
nothing's outside the bounds of god's
power
and so the way the the way they do all
these things again is looking at it as a
block
universe okay this notion that it's all
there the future's already there you're
just kind of walking on footsteps
okay every day of your life it's already
there
we're robots we're cartoon characters
that's the notion these people had
and then they also want you to have free
will so uh
yeah there is always that contradiction
and so people say well do we have free
will
because then you know if the robber
robbed the bank or the killer killed you
um did he have free will or did god
plan it already i mean was this guy just
walking on footsteps that he had no way
to avoid because
god already settled everything so this
was the issue okay so
this fight between determinism and free
will
was an important issue and these people
are getting into that world as well
but they the the difference here when he
says they have an advantage uh over st
augustine is that they're not only
bringing observation they're also
bringing equations saying
oh but we have the equations we have
proof we can we can prove
our theories because here's the equation
something augustine did not have
okay that's the way they look at it so
they yeah they vouch for the uh
universe but if the universe exists as a
block
then what is this nonsense about a big
bang it's like
the whole block is there you know did
the block come into being in one shot so
they have these contradictions where on
the one hand they have
a little dot called a singularity from
where where everything sprang
okay and then on the other hand they
also say well the future already exists
because we have the block
universe invented by mr augustine
apparently i don't know if there was
someone before him
uh and so so which is it is do we have a
blocked universe that we can't
escape because everything's already the
future's already there and we're just
walking on footsteps
or or are we talking about something
that is expanding
in in front of our eyes the universe you
know like the big bang is still
exploding
okay which is it we have contradictions
in the notions these people have
and obviously both of them are
irrational no matter how you look at it
so this notion of
big bang exploding and we're in the
middle of the explosion and
the fact that the future already exists
and we have the block universe both both
are nonsense both are idiocy invented by
mathematicians
and it wasn't even invented by them as
you can see it comes from people like
saint augustine
who who did it with god what he did to
just put god outside of the whole
shebang that's what it was okay and
these people say well let's get rid of
god altogether we don't need god and
we'll just
use the universe but they've got the
same black universe
that's that's where the problem is and
he
asks this is neil turk he says what is
dark energy and how does the
higgs fit into the scheme into that
scheme yeah
we got a problem because they they
invent all these particles like the
higgs
the sea of of mass
mass particles the con the particles of
a concept particles
of mass okay and how do you fit that
within dark energy which is the
so-called medium and for lack of a
spirit
that is pushing everything against the
gravitational pull that's why the
universe is expanding
so i mean you know they don't know how
to fit all these things together it's
like this guy
comes up he says oh i found the higgs
and they hit us a noble for that the
other guy said i found big bang
or dark energy okay you get a nibble for
that then how does it all fit together
do they have i mean if if the guy's got
a noble here and i've got an oval there
that means they proved to their
community you know within each
realm now how do we put it together can
we can we make sense of the higgs
together with
uh dark energy the answer is obviously
not it's like you know just give me my
noble and let someone else worry about
that problem
uh but he says the universe is telling
us that it is astonishingly
astonishingly simple yeah there's a
single thread that's all there is
it's always been there and that's how
simple it is the rope
is the simplest thing that you can
imagine for light for gravity for
everything so
yeah we have a simple universe it's the
mathematicians who made it complicated
but it turns out this is
uh neil turk's uh conclusion in that
discussion
the majority of the theoretical physics
uh community are very confused
no doubt i don't doubt that for a minute
i think he's right on that one i think
they have no clue whatsoever never had
in the last 400 years
why because they're not even following
the scientific method uh whatever they
had was the religious method
they were worried about more about
proving you know in doing equations than
about
understanding how this universe works
mechanistically
okay mechanically okay so here are my
conclusions
these uh individuals the debates all
and dissertations have no meaning until
they define the strategic words that
make or break their arguments
that's how simple it is that's where it
starts they are running around in
circles
math can't solve the problem of the
origin of matter so please keep your
math to yourself your equation to
yourself don't bring them into the
subject
into the discussion because they have no
uh bearing whatsoever on this topic
uh creation of something from nothing i
need the mechanism
okay and uh and here's the issue okay uh
i illustrate it so that people know what
i'm talking about here's god creating
matter for the first time can god do it
i mean god's all-powerful right
so i challenge god to do it this is what
god has to do okay
here we have the movie of the universe
okay or
of time or whatever you want to say and
god is outside of it fine great
uh i want to know how god goes from
frame five forty four
four and from frame 543 to five forty
four
i wanna know how in one cross section of
time one frame of the universal
film or heavenly film how we have
nothing
and suddenly in the next frame we have
something in zero time because each one
of those
uh frames represents the uh
you can say the shortest uh length of
time okay
so you can cut that down as far as you
want it's
infinitesimally small as much as you can
imagine how does god go from
uh frame 33 to 34 from 43 to 44. that's
that's the only question anyone has to
answer
okay so that's the issue before us not
even god can do that because
we cannot even imagine it and what god
would have to do is explain
the mechanism you know how he goes from
zip
absolutely nothing no vacuum phone or
quantum foam no
false vacuum nothing at all zip with a
zip
that which has no shape we want to know
how he goes from that which has no shape
to that which has shape
from that which has no shape till length
and height from that which has no
shape to form that's that's what that's
the question people have to answer
and if you cannot imagine a mechanism
it's an irrational issue
it can't happen it's just as simple as
that you can't say well it did happen
because here's the big bang
and we proved it and blah blah blah now
i don't care about the big bang i don't
care about the equations
i don't care about running the film
backwards of the exploding universe none
of that
um proves uh that
the universe started from zero meaning
and again the question is whether
they're talking about space being
created nothing being how do you create
nothing
and or matter which one are we talking
about we talked about how matter came
into existence or how space came into
existence
because if space is absolutely nothing
that which has no shape
uh what was there before there was
nothing
something we only have something in
nothing okay there is no third
possibility
and so if you start from absolute
nothing now which has no shape the only
issue is how do you create shape from
that
and as you can see not even god can do
it and then the question is irrational
anyway why because
y implies a creator it's already
embodied in the question when you say
why you're
this why it's not talking about cause
it's talking about
reason purpose okay and here let me
put it in a in a little more
graphic mode little illustration here
okay
this is the issue we have science what
is science science is
rational explanations that's what
science is about science is divided into
branches only two branches philosophy
and physics
physics deals with objects causes and
mechanisms and philosophy deals with
concepts reasons
and purpose and so when you say why
in this context you're invoking a
question of philosophy you're saying
reason and purpose okay why is there
something rather than nothing
and it turns out you're using a question
of philosophy of the branch of
philosophy and you're introducing it
into a context of physics
that's like the same thing as asking why
are there three dimensions why is the
speed of light 300 000 kilometers per
second
and so you're asking what is the reason
what is the purpose
in other words why did god do it that
way that's what you're asking
you're implying an intelligence
automatically it's embodied in the
question
okay you're not asking for a mechanism
you're asking for
what was the purpose what is the reason
okay and the reason is always the same
because god says so god wanted it so
and that's why the speed of light is uh
300 000 kilometers per second because
god said so
that's the answer to that it just is uh
there is no
answer to why it's 300 000 kilometers
per second precisely any more than the
uh mass of the electron or the proton or
any of those constants
the issue the issue here is another one
the issue is you have to ask
why is it constant now that's an
interesting question
why is it constant well because it's a
rope it's mediated by a rope that's why
the speed of light is a constant
then you can answer the question but
when you say why is the
why is uh space black well because space
is nothing
and what is nothing that which has no
shape it's a contrast to objects okay
that's why space is black
because god said so he it just is so
and and so there are no answers to such
questions because
the question is irrational you're asking
a question of
reason and purpose you're saying there
was an intelligence that deliberately
for some purpose of some reason because
he had a headache or whatever
decided to do something in such a way
that's what the person is asking
that's the answer to that question okay
okay um here's a coral area to that
okay and uh relativists have
repackaged saint augustine's block
universe under the guise of science
right
they call themselves atheists but make
no mistake they are religious fanatics
who try to rationalize their arguments
using
not scripture anymore you know but math
as authority
it is spiritualists who have always held
the reins of science
and who also ended up owning them even
today
the people who are in charge of
mathematical physics are all religious
fanatics
they're not rational individuals they're
not people who do things objectively
they do it completely subjective uh and
um
they they are they they're um
what i want to say here uh their
intention is to prove
to convince you to persuade you
especially through authority
not to give you an objective mechanism
of something that happened
okay so this is where the problem is and
so yeah they
and it's these type of people that end
up or ended up you know in charge of
mathematical physics which is equated to
science
and so people the few people on the
planet who still care about these things
they say
oh i'm going to follow so-and-so because
he's the scientist he's the
mathematician he knows all these
equations and he doesn't know who does
he's so intelligent you know they're the
wrong people because they're they're the
same as the
pastors of old or the priests of old you
know these
theologians of the dark ages uh
who interpreted the bible for you and
these guys are the same thing you're
relying on them to tell you
how to think because you say because you
give them the authority you say well
this guy has authority
look all the math he knows so what what
does math have to do with anything
okay and since by far most humans are
spiritualists the extinction of man
catches most which is
coming down our own okay catches most
people blindly following these
mathematical gurus
and that explains why the first two
fellows uh have so many millions of
followers because people
are suckers for that kind of uh double
talk that
circular talk they love it i guess they
love the poetry and that's why they're
entertained by
it i have no idea you figure it out